emergency services are at the scene of a
reported explosion at a service station
in Ireland's County Donegal images on
social media show severe damage to the
apple green service station just outside
the village of krislog for more I'm
joined on the phone now by councilor
John O'Donnell John thank you so much
for talking to us what happened
closing here uh just shortly after three
o'clock today uh
I've seen at the moment the whole entire
Bowden the front of the Bowden is
completely blown off it um
apartment locked up above as well and
have an accommodation above children not
sure if there was anybody residing in
that uh emergency services at the scene
uh their aired ambulances just after
taking off there with a number of
parties
um other than that they are just there
trying to clear up the rubble and
hopefully try and remove as many people
as we can probably saying it's it's just
it's very very hard to become here in a
small rural Village you know oh is that
what the scene is like there
yeah that's what the scenes like it's
just everybody's completely numbed here
we're just all in shock and we're
obviously not uh
um very close to the scene we know or we
don't want to be we're looking emergency
services do the job they're doing a
great job there's a massive amount of
them here and so we're just we're just
uh waiting to see what what
unfortunately that comes going to be
with us